the strip is busy as ever but for those
who work on it daily whether a vendor or
street performer the attack last
Thursday still looms over their head an
attack on eight people two of which were
stabbed to death Adriana Sai who sells
her jewelry near park in Las Vegas
Boulevard says after the shock set in of
what happened it was a wake-up call to
her and other Street vendors out there
we'll always try to stay aware and alert
about things on the Strip because I've
known a lot of previous things have
happened but definitely this has made me
you know make sure that I need to take a
self-defense class or you know do
something I definitely you know try to
stay in open parking spaces and you know
get to know a lot of the people on the
Strip so we all look out for each other
Psy also stating that she now plans out
her routes better as to where she is
going to sell making sure there is
visible security nearby
like street performer zuris Shepard
whose head is on a constant swivel I
have to protect my surroundings and look
out for the bad people and when I see
them call the police or have a security
guard in Wake of the attack many
wondering what kind of mental state
suspect Yani Barrios was in to Target
these random individuals Internal
Medicine specialist Dr Christopher Chow
weighs in stating that the challenge to
help those in need continues because of
the lack of physicians in our area last
week we saw something under a strip
which was horrible
until somebody lost it and ended up
stabbing a number of people
and I think we've been seeing more of uh
these issues in the last several years
because we as a society is undergoing a
lot of our stress and we don't know how
to deal with it
as for ramped up Security on this trip
we did see quite a bit but for how long
that will last it's unknown and we also
talked to talk to try to talk to show
girls around the strip just about what
recently happened as this is a recent
tragedy many of them declined to comment
reporting on this trip tonight Madison
Kimbrough eight news now